-Welcome to the show.
-Thank you. Thank you so muc
for having me.
-So, obviously, when you
undertake something like this,
you know you're gonna get to
speak to a lot of people.
You also know you're gonna
be open to criticism.
When you went into the first
debate, were you prepared for --
Because you became
very meme-able right away.
-Yes, very meme-able.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you enjoy those?
Were you suspecting that?
-They were mainly hilarious.
-Okay, good.
-So, I was down on the floor
laughing as much
as everybody was.
-We were watching
the first debate that night.
Kate McKinnon was on our show.
And I was watching the debat
live with her.
And when you first
started to speak,
it's the biggest I've ever see
her eyes get.
[ Laughter ]
Because she then immediately
had an impression of you.
-But do I have big eyes?
-No, just her eyes
got big with excitement
to have a political impression
that she could do that quickly
[ Laughter ]
Did you enjoy it?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-The vast majority of the stuf
around the memes and stuff
it wasn't malevolence there.
And I think that, you know
it's like what you were doin
earlier on the show.
First of all, political cartoons
and jokes goes back all the wa
to the beginning of our country,
and it's an important part o
our public discourse.
Look what you did earlier
this evening.
Very funny. Very funny.
And then somehow
that opened a space
and you got really serious
-I try.
-About trucking
and the harm being done.
And the fact you began it with
humor I think it's important
It opened the space.
-That's the trick.
[ Laughter ]
I know it has a place.
That's a good thing.
-You've talked about bringin
a moral compass to politics,
and I think, obviously,
that is drawing a distinctio
with what is happening right now
in the White House.
Do you think that moral compas
would be a platform
that would resonate
as much right now
if there was someone else
in the White House?
-Well, hopefully
we wouldn't need it
if somebody else
was in the White House,
but the issue is that he is.
And I don't believe we will beat
him with a political argumen
or an economic argument or eve
a purely rational argument
but we will beat him
with a moral argument.
He has no defense there
because he has no sense of
morality or ethics.
So he has no defense against it.
He can't engage.
-I think a lot of people,
certainly voters
in the Democratic primary,
have already reached the
conclusion that he is immoral,
which is the position you hold
and that some people are also --
Some criticism has been
that you have said that plan
are less important than drawin
this moral distinction.
How do you react to that?
-I have never said that plan
were less important
in terms of the presidency
I have talked about
how we defeat him in 2020.
And for that, I say, "Let'
remember, in the last election
we had
the most qualified candidate
and she certainly had plans.
All I'm talking about
when I talk about plans alon
will not get the job done
has to do with defeating him
in 2020."
You know, sometimes Democrat
don't realize --
I think a lot of us
don't realize,
the part of the brain that
rationally analyzes an issue
is not always
the same part of the brain
that decides who to vote for
So we have to have
a much more expanded,
much more integrative
political strategy
that includes psychology
and emotion,
and, yes, even spiritualit
and morality.
That's where people live
and that's where you vote from
-Are you finding it hard in th
constraints of a debate format
to get across a message
of spirituality
and morality and psychology?
'Cause it's just you have
small chunks of time to talk
and I think ultimately,
even if you have specific plans,
they are 90-second
chunks of time.
Have you been frustrated by that
when you're out there?
-Well, except for Montana,
I was the most Googled person.
-You were the most Googled
person in Montana?
[ Laughter ]
-No. No.
I was the most --
After the second debate,
I was the most Googled perso
except Montana because --
-Oh, Steve Bullock, right.
-Steve Bullock.
They didn't know
who their governor was.
So I'm saying --
[ Laughter ]
So I think I'm doing okay.
-Yeah.
I'm sorry. Well, look.
Obviously, you know,
hopefully tonight
people in Montana
will be Googling.
-I love Montana.
-Don't pander.
[ Laughter ]
-You can't say anything.